Let's go next to Luciane from England, you're
on the air.
Hello, David, how are you?
I'm good, how are you?
I'm doing well.
All right, so, um, so I saw that a few days
ago, you responded to a caller who was asking
about the idea of having conversations with
other public speakers like yourself, but on
the right.
Yes.
And I'm sorry you spoke about it again since,
but I haven't quite caught up on this, OK?
You seemed very open to the idea at the end
of that.
And I think you asked the audience if they'd
be interested.
Right.
So my thoughts.
I've had thoughts on this for a while, wanted
to speak to you about it because I think I'm
quite worried that people can become quite
insular and sort of stick to their own kind.
So to say I'm taking everything these people
say is gospel.
And I wonder to what extent you think this
has contributed to the polarization we see
today.
You're saying that maybe not enough conversations
between left and right are happening and that
leads to more polarization.
Yes.
And if you did say and understand that you
said, it's quite hard to make it a productive
thing.
Yeah, maybe.
Especially if you're trying to speak to the
likes of Tucker.
But would you be sort of willing to try it
and maybe leave maybe sort of like lead by
example to get the public to be more open
to bipartisanship?
Yeah, I mean, listen, here's the thing.
The call that I got last week from people
saying why not do more of the kind of like
blood sport type debates with kooky right
wingers?
That's very different than when, like, for
example, I had on Neil Ferguson, who's someone
from the right who we can engage in a more
meaningful way to hopefully try to understand
each other.
Or like when I had on who else, there's a
there's a bunch of different people I've had
on where it's sort of more normal in a sense.
I think that that's great.
And I have been doing that and continue to
do that.
I think that the question from the from the
caller was more like more cartoonish debates
with Tim Pool or like the Westboro Baptist
Church lunatics or stuff like that, where
that I don't see as as productive.
But, you know, like when I have Neil Ferguson
on or people like that, I think that that
that that is good.
And I plan to continue doing that.
Yes, I really hope it's making a difference.
I just think both sides really love to demonize
each other so much.
Yeah, I think if if the people we look up
to for this kind of information, if we see
them sit down and talk constructively, it
won't fix the problem.
But I think it could go a long way.
I don't disagree.
I'm completely on board.
And yeah, my interpretation of last week's
question was more about like the wacky right
wingers, where it's just like, you know, how
much do we really it's like funny to do a
Jesse Lee Peterson interview, but it's kind
of a waste of time, too, of course.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
All right, thank you so much.
Yeah, very, very good point.
Glad to have the opportunity to clarify and
explore further.